نحن الان امام المبنى الذي سقط في حيفا
وسط مدينه اورفا سقطت في خيار هذا البنات
عدد من القتلى والجرحى في هذا المكان كذلك
الامر
كذلك الامر سقطت العديد من الابنيه في
ولايه شارلي اوروبا بحسب بعض عناصر
الاطفاء
الطبيه بانه سته عشر بنا تم تدمرت جرار
هذه الهزه الارضيه في ولايه شان اورفا
اعداد ضحايا كبيره جدا حقيقه في هذا
البناء عندما وصلنا بعد 20 دقيقه من يعني
سقوطه كان هناك بعض الصيحات من داخل هذا
البناء من
اهالي هذا البناء بناء مؤلف كما ترون من
خمس طوابق سقطت جميعها على الارض كذلك
الامر في حي الشهير سقط بناء ايضا مكون من
ست طوابق سقط فيه ثمانيه قتله وعدس كبير
من الجرح كذلك الامر في حي احمد ارصوان
ايضا بداخل ولايه شارلي اورفا
عدد من الابنيه واحد منها سقط فيه ايضا
عدد من القتلى والجراحه حتى الان لا توجد
اي احصائيه رسميه كما ترون خلفي تماما
عمليات الانقاذ تجري في هذا البناء يعني
لا يوجد اي حصيله نهائيه لهذه العمليه ما
هو ماساوي اكثر هو درجات الحراره المنخفضه
في هذه المنطقه التي يعني بسبب هذه الهزه
خرج الاهالي الى الساحات والى الحدائق
والشوارع خوفا من الضربات الاعتداديه ومن
الهزه الارضيه الهزه الارضيه التي ضربت
المنطقه الان الاهالي جميعهم كما ترون
خلفي تماما منتشرون في الحدائق والشوارع
هنا عمليات اللجنه تتم في
حيلولر جرار سقوط هذا البناء المكون خمس
طوابق